who can help to find climate change
safeguard Europe's natural resources and
protect and preserve the EU countryside
the answer is our farmers often in the
environmental front line working hard to
produce enough food for more than 500
million Europeans while coping with the
adverse effects of a changing climate in
doing this
farmers are providing public benefits
for which they receive support from the
European Union under the Common
Agricultural Policy or cap recent reform
has made the cap greener to ensure
better protection of our soil and water
quality and to safeguard biodiversity
farmers are also encouraged to adopt
even more eco-friendly production
methods such as organic farming
significant investment in research in
technology helps farmers to put in place
innovative farming methods to support
the sustainability of Agriculture
the new cat promotes the careful use of
our finite natural resources this is
essential both for the production of
healthy nutritious food and for our
quality of life today tomorrow and for
future generations
Europe's Common Agricultural Policy
taking care of our roots
you